[Music]
[Music]
malice played a rather essential role in
breath the wild's narrative
not only as a way to explain calamity
ganon's nature and how he was able to
turn the sheik attack against the
kingdom but also as a means of
environmental storytelling
we've seen firsthand the devastation
this hate-filled substance can cause to
that which it comes into contact with
not only can it possess and override
machinery is deadly to the touch
but it also seems to be able to sap the
life force out of organic life forms
rendering once green fields and
vegetation dead and decayed
in breath of the wild the main focus lay
on the influence malice has on
technology when calamity ganon houses
parts of its malice inside a guardian
for instance
it essentially becomes part of its
global consciousness so technically
every machine
blight and malice eye you encounter is
ganon staring you right in the face
a very creepy concept machinery aside we
got a few small glimpses of its
influence on organic creatures as well
the cursed mccobblens moblins and
lisophos are said to have been given
sort of a life after death
devoid of any intelligence due to the
influence of malice
additionally we encountered one of the
three dragon spirits nedra infested and
incapacitated by malice
four years after breath of the wild cui
tecmo spin-off title
age of calamity expanded the lore behind
malice even further
it confirmed that even the tiniest
sliver of malice is enough to transfer
ganon's entire consciousness
and can even transcend time itself it
also introduced various malice-based
enemies making them even more deadly
than they were originally
but perhaps the most interesting
revelation was the effect it can have on
other races besides monsters
although we saw the influence of malice
on nedra the dragon spirits of hyrule
are classified as spirits or deities
setting them apart from the average life
form and thus it's hard to say what
rules apply when it comes to what malice
can actually do to them
nedra seemed disoriented and confused as
if struck by an
illness but it wasn't hostile to its
environment and didn't even bother to
attack link himself
it didn't fly around and went on a
killing spree as we saw the guardians do
hinting that gannon didn't have full
control over nedra's mind and body we of
course don't know what would have
happened to nedra
hadling not freed it from ganon's
influence whether it would have just
stayed like this or if ganon eventually
would have gotten full control over it
or if it would have withered away and
slowly died
well as much as the spirit can die
anyway
enter the most recent addition to the
collection of zelda villains
aster although we don't know much about
the prophet of doom he is revealed to be
a hylian originating from a small
village in hyrule somewhere
a guy who threw the power granted to him
by calamity ganon served the demon king
in his plan to take over hyrule in this
timeline
but as is often the case when dealing
with ganon aster was nothing more than
just a pawn
a puppet to be used in ganon's plan and
once that puppet's role had expired
aster became expendable and his death
was
not exactly a pleasant one
peace
in a state of shock and confusion aster
cannot do anything but watch as the
malice slowly consumes his flesh
starting with his arm and then spreading
to his face and subsequently the rest of
his body
until nothing of him remains and he
himself has become part of calamity
ganon which brings us to the recent
trailer
[Music]
now that we've seen what malice can do
to a living person
rather than a machine or a spirit we can
make a pretty accurate prediction
as to the fate of link's arm in the
sequel and as a matter of fact we do get
a small glimpse of the effect the malice
had on his body in the new trailer
this is also why the part about aster
was important to mention
when asta gets absorbed by malice his
skin turns black
and we see that a similar thing has
happened to link underneath the bracelet
his skin has turned black as well
it's most visible in the shot where he's
soaring down from the sky
but it's observable in other shots as
well such as this one
it's even visible when he's wearing the
champion's outfit link is seen wearing
gloves with open fingertips throughout
both trailers
yet here one hand has normal fingertips
while the other has black ones
in the shot of his arm up close we can
see the discoloration of his skin as
well
here it's mostly green but as the glow
starts to dim you can see the top part
of the scars becoming darker and darker
it also becomes apparent that when he's
using the hen's power the scarred part
of his skin becomes green
and when he's not it turns black again
so yeah the malice
sure did a number on link and it didn't
stop at just his arm either
even the right side of his torso has
angular looking scars all over it
showing just how far the malice
infection spread
and just as a side note these scars on
link's body have some pretty strong
resemblances to the one
zelda has in twilight princess which is
when ganondorf possesses her body
it also just so happens to be the game
where ganondorf first started showing
the ability to transform into malice
like clouds and house himself
or his power into other beings something
he wasn't capable of in ocarina of time
and the wind waker
just some food for thought i firmly
believe that had the green hand
not intervened link could have
potentially suffered a similar fate to
that of astor
a total spread of malice all over his
body until it consumed him whole
luckily whatever this being is it seems
to have been on link's good side and put
a damper on the infection before it
could spread any further which i'm sure
is also where the bracelet comes into
play
another thing i've discussed a couple of
times during my live streams is that i
find it quite suspicious that aside from
the shot at the very beginning
they never show a clear depiction of the
right side of his face
in fact they barely show his face at all
the closest we get is a part of his
right cheek and nose but in every other
shot link is either not facing the
camera at all or they only show his left
side
it is a bit odd since we know what link
looks like
it's not exactly a mystery at this point
granted the trailer did mostly consist
of gameplay which is generally
experienced from the back of the
character
even in the 2016 trailer for breath the
wild we don't see his face
much though they do show it on some
occasions even in the 2014 reveal they
showed his face clear as day
same goes for the 2019 trailer for the
sequel perhaps i'm thinking too deep
into this and it's just a coincidence
but i don't think it's out of the realm
of possibility that the infection may
have reached parts of his face
similar to aster he could potentially
have some scars around his eye for
instance
or maybe one of his eyes is damaged or
discolored or turned into a malasi
similar to ganondorfs which kinda
reminds me of district 9.
awesome movie by the way now normally
there wouldn't be a reason to think this
if not for the fact that nintendo has
published concept art for breath the
wild where some weird stuff is happening
to link's arm just like we see now with
the sequel trailer and in all these
concepts
link's face is affected as well it's
either bandaged up or straight up looks
like a weird
deformed mess from the looks of it they
didn't go that far
since his cheeks and his nose still look
normal on both sides
but how unsettling would it be if it
turns out that link is partially
possessed by ganondorf one of his eyes
having turned yellow or burning with
malice
after all in twilight princess zelda's
eyes also changed color when she was
possessed
and we see something similar happening
to zelda in spirit tracks when they're
fighting maladus an entity who's known
for being able to control people's life
force
also malice malados but anyway that's
just heavy speculation for now and we'll
just have to wait and see if this ends
up being true
you might have also noticed that when
link is seemingly laying unconscious on
the floor he's suddenly down to his
boxers again
i'm sure this will tie into the reason
why link starts out with three hearts
again and such
obviously they have to somehow set link
back to square one again as is always
tradition in zelda games
an attack on link by malice which has
severely scarred him and maybe even
zapped parts of his life force would be
sufficient as a plot device to get this
done
the question is from a story perspective
how does link suddenly go from fully
decked out in clothing to
practically naked it's pretty clear that
this is still part of the same sequence
of events
inside the cave and their encounter with
ganondorf well again when we look at the
scene with astor
it's not just his skin being affected
his entire cloak turns black along with
him
of course at some point nintendo decides
to cut away
after which aster is completely gone
clothing and all because
you know pg-13 and all but given the
nature of malice and how it's able to
scorch trees and burn grass away
it's not unreasonable to think that
malice has some sort of an acidic or
flammable element to it which can easily
eat through or burn organic material
like clothing
now you would think that well wouldn't
only his sleeve be gone then
well i mean we never see how far the
malice actually reaches
it travels up his arm pretty damn quick
and might have reached other parts of
his body
maybe there's even tendrils of malice
climbing up his feet as well
we don't know since the shot only lasts
a few frames either way the damage is
apparently big enough that he ends up
half naked and unconscious on the floor
which also ties into the last subject of
the video which is
the fate of the master sword after the
opening flash of link the master sword
is never seen again
all we see him carry after this point is
a traveler's sword the weakest highland
made sword in the game
so something bad definitely happened to
it and narrative wise this makes sense
the master sword is the one thing that
can actually inflict mortal damage to
ganondorf
in fact link's arm may have not even
been his main target but rather a
byproduct of ganondorf going after the
master sword from there the malice
traveled up the blade and onto link's
arm and body so the master sword might
be either completely gone or at the very
least heavily damaged by the malice
in breath of the wild we also saw the
effect malice has on the sword
as creating a champion confirms that
these black spots on the master sword
are malice not rust which is what i
initially thought
and that was just from fighting
guardians so you can imagine the immense
damage this pure bright malice straight
from the demon king himself can inflict
and again this would tie perfectly into
the concept art we've covered earlier
here too we can see link carrying a
broken master sword in one of the
depictions this could even play a
central role in the story
trying to find a way to restore the
master sword in order to get a rematch
against ganondorf this could even
explain the absence of the deku tree in
one of the shots from the new trailer
it's unmistakably not there even though
if we visit this exact location in
breath of the wild
it should be visible quite clearly so
draw distance definitely isn't the issue
some have chalked this up to time travel
that this game takes place
at least partially in a time before the
deku tree was born
ten thousand years ago is especially
thrown around a lot but there are some
big problems with this
first is the fact that this ruin we see
right here are the ruins of lon lon reg
if this takes place 10 000 years ago why
would these ruins be here in the exact
same state as they were in the present
wouldn't the ranch either not be there
because it hasn't been built yet or
still in a pristine state like we saw
100 years ago in age of calamity
on top of that we can also spot akala
citadel in the distance
another modern hylian building and not
an ancient one
i'd also like to remind people that if
this took place 10 000 years ago the
deku tree would most likely already be
born and all grown up the deku tree is
incredibly old and states himself that
he has been around since time immemorial
10 000 years is likely nothing for the
guardian of the forest
even creating a champion confirms that
he is likely seeing countless calamities
a more simple explanation for the
absence of the deku tree is that korok
forest
may have been targeted by ganondorf
after his awakening and could have
killed the deku tree
it definitely wouldn't be the first time
in ocarina of time it was because the
deku tree simply refused to give him the
kokiri emerald which he sought after to
open the door to the sacred realm but in
breath of the wild it carries even more
weight story wise one of the lead
artists of the game explains that the
deku tree taps into the energy of the
land
which allows for the restoration of the
master sword and is why the pedestal is
located
at the foot of the tree obviously
ganondorf would want to prevent link
from restoring the sword again so
killing the only known being capable of
restoring the blade makes perfect sense
when we finally get more details about
the game in the coming months and into
2022 we'll be able to see
exactly what the effects of malice on
link's arm as well as the master sword
will be
but until then i think we have a pretty
good general idea
it's the details that require a bit more
explanation
maybe link's face will be screwed up or
maybe it's just his arm
perhaps the master sword simply drops
into the chasm below during the attack
and it is zelda who has some sort of a
story arc involving the blade
given that she survives this fall only
time will
tell and that is all for now a big
thanks to you for watching to my mods
who keep my discord alive and monitor my
chat during my live streams and of
course to my patreon supporters and
channel members who make these videos
possible
a shout out to the newcomers which are
as follows
nicolas mirage julie eisenring tiny elf
sebastian chobar talus roon zaydon
dragmar
marcelo carmago sah lit 8 bit
not so heroic link and zelda connection
a big round of applause for this amazing
turn up as always
words cannot do it justice thank you so
much please look forward to a big
collaboration theory coming up with none
other than the biggest
zelda tuber out there which is of course
mr celtic himself
we are both very excited to present this
big two-part theory to you guys
very soon so keep an eye out for that
this is dawn signing off and
have a good one